ces fins de sortie ça me permet de
sélectionner savoir que dès qu'on y
viennent habillés en fait on n'a pas
vraiment croit on apprend mais parce que
si on est un peu au milieu de la nature
les vertus de l'apprentissage en plein
air sont prouvées mais entre la théorie
et la pratique régulière l'école à ciel
ouvert impose toute une logistique
particulièrement au secondaire c'est les
autobus de faire approuver par l'école
par les parents il faut que mes horaires
soient faites aussi en conséquence donc
ça prend ça prend de l'ajustement mais
je vous dirais que le plus difficile
c'est un essai c'est le manque de
chauffeurs d'autobus scolaires
il y a une dizaine de profils plein air
dans les écoles secondaires du grand
montréal celui de l'école monseigneur
tard en se distingue parce qu'il combine
science et plein air ça va tellement 100
meilleurs tellement de choses à raconter
quand on mènera
au parc des îles de boucherville la
théorie prend vie on y voit ce qui peut
menacer les équilibres de la nature
l'invasion de phragmites qui prennent la
place des quenouilles ayant deux
manières de ce projet qui est censé des
plantes envahissantes ou encore
l'absence de glace sur le fleuve pendant
plusieurs divergent à travers fait en
ski sur les lycées parce que le fleuve
était complètement gelé
c'est donc beaucoup plus qu'une sortie
de ski de fond et qui a commencé en
classe de sciences je peux pas bouger la
feuille tout le ce qui touche à la nage
est ce que vous comprenez bien le prince
a en quelques années ce programme créé
en fusionnant des périodes de sciences
et d'éducation physique est devenue très
populaire j'aime aussi beaucoup à
prendre les points techniques des sports
afin qu on est en train d'apprendre
comment forte équipe c'est très
important
à l'école de la dauversière à montréal
c'est la nécessité qui a favorisé la
mise en place d'un profil plein air pour
les élèves de première et deuxième
secondaire en septembre dernier dès les
premiers jours de l'année je leur ai dit
on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas des
menaces on va sortir à tous les corbeaux
temps mauvais temps
la direction de cette école qui manque d
espace à chercher un enseignant en
éducation physique spécialisé en plein
air urbain on peut rappeler les contenus
mort même à -10 degrés celsius les
jeunes occupent le parc public situé
juste en face de leur école on à faire
un conte un mini camp avec deux un mac
on doit faire un sofa de neige que vous
avec le gouverneur on a de l'ambition
pour ce profil plein air qui intéressent
d'autres enseignements de ce projet
cette vision de prendre le prétexte du
plein air et de l'amener au service de
l'apprentissage des autres matières
faudrait être dans plus d'école qu'on
pense tout ce qui est les heurts ont
besoin c'est d'être grand temps de mieux
respirer pendant qu'on travaille ça aide
la réflexion humain vise ont choisi ce
programme là pour ça donc l'eau
enfin on peut sortir vivement un retour
à la normale pour que les élèves de
madame bouchard puissent reprendre leur
sortie scientifique habituellement une
dizaine par année ici anne louise
despatie radio-canada morère